hi
i'm siddharth agarwal and i'm
responsible for our sas partnerships
here at google
and the co-innovation that we do with
our isvs
i wanted to welcome you to this session
today which is going to talk about how
isbs are accelerating the digital
transformation that their customers are
asking them for
and how these isps and sas companies are
co-innovating
with google to deliver that
transformation
and we also have a very exciting
customer story to share with you
on how the isb has actually driven
that co-innovation leveraging both
google capabilities
and gcp capabilities or google cloud
platform capabilities
so isps are being asked to
accelerate the digital transformation by
their customers
and in order to deliver this the isvs
are on
a number of cloud journeys and i'd love
to share with you these cloud journeys
and then talk about some customer
examples and
also how google is using co-innovation
to help the isvs on these cloud journeys
so starting off with the multi-cloud
expansion side of it
most isv and sas partners are being
asked to leverage cloud
to deliver higher availability which
might mean
delivering an active active dr site or
bursting into the cloud
or to modernize their on-premise
applications which might involve
lifting and shifting existing on-prem
assets or
actually moving out of complete data
centers or to expand into regions with
significant compliance and data
residency requirements
and most importantly to keep increasing
the security
that infrastructure security their user
security
their data security security is
paramount
and so to help our isvs along these
journeys
we have built a number of capabilities
in our platform for example anthos
temenos which is a financial services
isv leveraged anthos
which is a financial services
application delivered on premise
to be able to actually burst when
additional capacities needed into the
cloud with an
active active architecture or be able to
create a dr scenario
where in case something went wrong on
premise the application would be live
at any given point in time from the
public cloud
also google's focused a lot on planet
scale by delivering the world's largest
network
which was built for applications like
search and youtube
and gmail to enable isvs to reach their
customers where they are
and from a security perspective
providing innovations like
confidential compute using amd's
in-memory encryption
and our titan security chips on our
hardware to deliver
significant security and openness
is a key tenant for google where we have
a long-standing history of championing
open source
and extending that to google cloud by
making open source a first-class citizen
this could be for third-party open
source such as kafka or confluent
but as you very well know also
kubernetes and istio
which has led the transformation of
modernizing
application development every
organization is focused on innovating to
differentiate
and isvs have to innovate to compete
more effectively
to grow top line by expanding into new
markets
in order to do this they're asking how
intelligence can be leveraged to make
business processes
more automated and predictable without
needing a lot of data scientist skills
and how their users can be engaged via
voice and messaging
so for example on intelligence how can
they deliver better business outcomes
how can they get insight from documents
how can they do multilingual
translations
in real time and user experience
is now no longer about just
browser-based experiences
so using virtual agents intelligent
chatbots
and even search as the new paradigm for
interaction
and it's become really important to be
able to use
industry-specific solutions to deliver
industry-specific solutions to your
customers
which means delivering intelligence for
retail or delivering solutions that are
specific to
financial services or the public sector
given the scale at which data is being
generated
insight from this data can no longer be
derived with on-prem
traditional infrastructure you know be
it around compute or around storage
so customers are asking isps how they
can get insights from
and act upon data at exabyte and
petabyte scale
and this involves being able to leverage
streaming data and batch data
to be able to make intelligent decisions
on the streaming data that is coming in
as the data is coming in to be able to
blend first-party data and third-party
data first-party data that might be in
the isvs application
and third-party data that might be
coming from outside
and enable business users at these
customers
to be able to make those decisions such
that they don't have to be data
scientists they don't have to know aiml
they can just be getting value from that
data and then we're going to talk about
this
in the customer story or the isv story
is really about personalization and
segmentation
how can you be able to personalize the
engagement with the customers
using broader data that might could come
from google it could come from google
ads it could come from google search etc
or being able to segment the audience
and being able to target the audience in
the way you want
so to that end what we've done is one
we're providing a very rich set of aiml
capabilities and very strong aiml
capabilities
to be able to for example get insight
from vision from speech etc
but we've also built solutions on top of
the ai
so for example we built a contact center
ai solution
where in real time as customers are
talking
we're understanding the intent of those
customers and having a virtual agent
be able to engage with that customer
across multiple turns
without needing an agent involved at all
being able to do that in
real time where the data is running on
our tpus the analysis is running on our
tpus
being able to get insight from the
conversations that are being had
and if the answer cannot be solved by
the virtual agent themselves
being able to transfer that over to a
live agent
and being able to provide that agent
with intelligent insight
on how to respond and what is the next
best action that they should be
suggesting
similarly from documents being able to
get insight from documents
uh for example from a a mortgage
document
you know how do you understand what is
the rate what is the financing terms etc
or from a license being able to
understand is this a valid driver's
license
which state does this driver's license
belong to or from contracts being able
to get the sense of
what terms have been agreed to
limitation of liability etc
and then from an analytics lens being
able to provide you the ability to
stream in data
at large scale into bigquery where you
can we've separated our compute and
storage
such that you can analyze this data at
scale
blend the data at scale with you know
petabytes of data being crunched on
at the same time and then you can
actually build monetization models on
top of this data
where customers who have really large
amounts of data that is really valuable
data that they want to be able to share
out
and monetize they can actually do very
granular access to that data
they can do governance and access
control to the data
and they can monetize the data from
bigquery itself
so lots of really cool capabilities that
have been delivered
for both of those journeys to
differentiate with innovation
and to be able to get insight from
real-time data and what's really
exciting
is how isvs have not only been doing
co-innovation
with google cloud platform but the
broader google properties
that includes google pay google shopping
android
chrome etc for example in retail
isvs are looking at how they can
leverage google shopping to be able to
uh optimize the price that is being
offered up by merchants that are selling
on their platform
or to be able to improve the merchant
discoverability
that exists for merchants on their
platform onto google shopping
and we'll be talking about how google
ads are being used by
that isv and also these isps are working
on delivering very
smart industry and horizontal solutions
by embedding intelligence to deliver
business processes that
are much better in understanding what
should be happening what is the customer
looking for
in various specific industries now one
of the key areas is around developer
engagement
developers as we know are the new king
makers and everyone is focused on how to
get these developers attached to the
platform
and so isvs are looking at how we can
help the developers
upskill with new technologies such as
containerization
micro services aiml and really around
devops and sre
because we delivering applications at
scale like gmail
and how can they improve their devops
and sre capabilities
to deliver that same capability at large
scale
what's really interesting is we found
the developers are trying to
provide insight into product analytics
to the product manager
so which features are being used what
functionality is being used
and what are some informed intelligent
recommendations and how to enhance
the usage of the product and then you
know no
sas application or no application out of
the box delivers all the value that is
needed
so isvs are also looking at building a
rich extension platform
for example leveraging our apigee
capabilities to provide api exposure
and to be able to monetize and manage
those apis
or to provide business logic extensions
that can ride alongside
the isv or sas application
and then we're very focused on
partnering for joint success with the
isps
the isps have asked us what we're doing
to invest in developing and innovating
with you
how we can increase the joint good
market with the isvs
and how we can accelerate distribution
with the isvs
so we're making co-investment decisions
to provide unique product
engineering or co-innovation funds
defining joint go to market
with joint verticalization market
expansion planning
or global regional field alignment and
accelerated distribution being able to
leverage the google field being able to
leverage the google cloud marketplace
and find the executive alignment and a
focus on customer success
how do we make sure that our customers
are going live
are on boarding and being really
successful so these are the ways that
we're working with the isvs to enable
their journeys to the cloud
to deliver multi-cloud capabilities to
deliver intelligence embedded within
their own solutions including for
industry-specific
use cases and driving co-innovation
that's not just about google cloud but
also the broader google
product areas with that i'm really
excited to invite
to this discussion guy helya from
opentext
whose team has done an amazing job at
driving co-innovation to deliver value
to their customers welcome guy hello
sidhartha thank you very much
great to have you on this uh discussion
here
so can you just do a little background
on your shelf and open text
sure i'm responsible for product
management in our digital experience
product unit opentext is a very large
information management solutions company
and so we focus on digital experience
content services business network
information security
and how that all helps our customers to
transform and in the area of digital
experience that's really
about helping our brand customers be
able to drive conversions
of for customers with through digital
experience
to grow revenue and to do that on all
the different
channels that a customer journey and
touch points that a customer journey
occurs on
that's wonderful guy so it sounds like
you know marketers are going to be very
happy with your solution because it
drives
higher conversion and top line for them
so can you share an example
of how this might be experienced both by
an end customer
of your customer and by the marketing
organization in your customer
sure so let's take uh purchasing a house
and uh if uh you know as a customer
a target customer of mine is purchasing
a house then they're looking for a new
house insurance
uh provider uh they might be they might
come from a different
set of backgrounds maybe different
interests geographies
and so as they're searching on my site
for
uh for product information anonymously
the google marketing platform is able to
help understand and model their behavior
and then what we're trying to do is
on that site help the our brand
customers be able to provide the most
relevant experience for those customers
knowing knowing their interests and just
being able to
to target and to personalize in the most
effective way whether that's on the site
a mobile app
in the contact center as you've already
discussed in any type of touch point
chat any of those that's
exciting so they get dynamic landing
pages
delivered to them and the experience is
same even if they start the transaction
on one channel
and continue their transaction across
the other channels
so you know this question is coming guy
but
what made you think of google or
partnering with google what is unique
about google that helped you deliver the
solution to your customers
well as we've talked about i think the
the thing that our customers are
interested in is how to make sure that
the customer's journey
is as relevant as possible to make sure
that that customer
understands the products really well and
and finds the right products and
services
and how to use them in the in the long
run that means
being able to help both anonymous users
and customers as well as the known and
the logged in customer
and to do this you need content you need
a lot of content
and you need the data the information
the context
and the understanding of that
information of that context to make the
experience really relevant
so our experience platform helps to
deliver
brand experiences customer portals
commerce experiences communications all
of these
while the marketing platform is
delivering that same
brand experience through advertising
into so many different touch points that
are off
the site delivered by google marketing
platform so the first place
that we've innovated has been around
understanding content
and as you've already talked about
content comes in many different forms
of course media imagery it can be audio
voice it could be all kinds of audio
that goes with video
of course understanding video and the
nature of video
intelligence for that and being able to
translate content
so we worked with all of those those
solutions with our experience platform
and the ability to run it on the google
cloud platform
but we're also innovating around the use
of data
together with both bigquery and uh the
the google marketing platform that's
amazing
integration that you've done or your
team has done
working with google so can we dive just
a little bit deeper
into vision ai or automl how did he use
that to make a marketer's job a lot
easier
yeah great question and this is really
where rubber meets the road so
in with all of this content and all of
these experiences
marketers need tools that allow them to
understand it to automate it to work
with it
without having to do a lot of manual
effort so
so vision ai all of the the ai media
centric ai tools
they help us specifically to be able to
pull out is there a bicycle in this
image or to be able to understand that
that there is a bicycle it's
outdoors or maybe there's branding logos
that are in
a particular image or maybe there's
actually a product
that's displayed or being referenced
here all of that information is really
critical to be able to automate
what a marketer works with in the first
place and then allow that tagging to be
used even to
to deliver uh advertising in a more
accurate and relevant way
so that the marketing platform can use
that tagging uh to be
very relevant for end customers and so
that
whether it's on images or on video or on
speech
all of that that that cognitive
understanding of content is really
important
that's great that gave me goosebumps as
you were talking about it into the kind
of insight that you were able to get
so i know you've worked with the isv sas
center of excellence that we launched
earlier this year
can you share a little bit about how
they helped you on this journey
yeah great question and and this is
where i want to bring in the big query
side
of things because customers have so much
third-party data they have transactions
they have information about their
products they have information about
customers from their crm systems
they have all kinds of very specific
first-party data
that bringing those models together with
the advertising audiences it allows
customers to build a very rich learning
model
to understand how to augment the
audiences and to be able to target
and so we've worked with the center of
excellence to be able to understand how
the google cloud services can can enable
that
how we integrate that with our our
experience platform
uh and and how it rolls out for the
customer they've been instrumental to
understand the modeling
and how that actually gets used by our
customers
great now i'm really proud to hear that
the sas center of excellence has been
helpful in defining the architecture in
working hands-on with you to put a poc
together
and to you know help you feel
comfortable around the platform
so thank you so much guy this is
wonderful
and it's this kind of innovation when an
isv like open text
leverages google marketing platform
which is outside of google cloud uses
ai from the google cloud platform
leverages bigquery for large-scale data
and then deploys all of this on google
cloud platform to deliver a
brand new product for themselves that
differentiates them
and delivers significant value to their
customer and to their customers customer
so if there's one message i want you to
take away it's this
it's not about what is but what could be
it's not about what exists but what we
can create together
nothing is impossible and failure should
be welcomed
to learn from and help create 10x
opportunities
that's google culture that's google
co-innovation to feel comfortable with
failure
learn and then create 10x opportunities
think not just about gcp or google cloud
platform but the broader google
capabilities of google ads google
marketing platform
search android chrome etc
we're providing a canvas we're providing
brushes
and a beautiful palette of colors and we
look forward to seeing you paint your
vibrant masterpieces onto this canvas
please come share your ideas with us
we're here to help
thank you